[Music]
arena is with us in portland oregon hi
arena how are you
hi dave i am better than i deserve
good how can we help
uh thank you so much for taking my call
it's such an honor to speak with you
um so my husband and i are in baby steps
four five and six and i know that means
fifteen percent of total household
income um invested towards retirement
um i am wondering based on our situation
so we're pretty young we already have
about 27 000 for retirement which i made
me and my
um husband then he was my boyfriend um i
made us invest that when we were in high
school
and using the investment calculator um
so right now both of us are working i
recently graduated from college that
freak
and using the investment calculator i
saw that you know if i'm if we're
putting in a thousand each month then in
2055 when we want to retire at a 10
return we'll we'll have about 4 million
um which is
very very comfortable for us
um so i was wondering if it would be a
good idea to keep investing that 1000
which is about 15 of my income and then
we would use my husband's 15 of his
income um and whatever else we can save
apart from uh for our kids and new car
and everything um to hopefully
to go towards the house and hopefully
pay that off soon so that
later i can i can um leave work raise
the kids and yeah we can continue to
save that a thousand for retirement and
have some wiggle room uh when we go back
to just one salary so let me recap you
want to invest seven and a half percent
of your household income to create
wiggle room to fund other life goals
effectively yes
no i would invest 15 percent total he
invest 15 you invest 15. it doesn't
matter how it shakes down as long as
it's 15 percent of your household income
and you guys should have the margin to
fund everything else
what's your household income
um right now it'll be about 145
with before taxes okay well let me help
you with this
your um
assumptions
were that you kept investing the exact
same amount for your entire life
yeah and which would assume that you
made no more money
so you started at 145 and never got a
raise for 50 years
yeah not a realistic assumption agreed
yeah so so you're going to have more
than four million and you're going to
have the house paid off even quicker
than you thought
both
it's hard to see it with the numbers
because
um if we're
if we're investing 15 percent of our
total income it seems like it'll take
not it seems um we're heading the
numbers it'll take so how much do you
owe on your house
um
we have a loan out for i think around
300.
all right and so if you pay thirty
thousand dollars a year on the house in
ten years it's gone
right
and if you pay fifty thousand dollars a
year on the house
out of 145
it's gone in what
six years
okay
so between six and seven years or
between six and ten years your home's
gonna be paid off how old are you
i'm 21 my husband's 23. he'll be 31. ooh
ancient
i don't know how you're going to get
around when you're 31 be awful
but
honey you are doing so good
chill out and follow the baby steps
they work
you're going to be fine you're not only
going to get the house paid off before
you think you're going to you're going
to have more at retirement than you
think you're going to
because you're going to get raises that
you didn't factor into your equation
and so when the math is talking to you
with the wrong assumptions it's telling
you the wrong things
okay yeah it was using that base number
just to see like
it's a good it's a good exercise to go
through but it's not a good exercise
it's not a good exercise to allow your
emotions to kick in because of
so you know and listen did you hear what
you just said to me you're 22 years old
you guys make 145
000 dollars
you understand where that puts you
that's like rock star stuff you're
amazing
praise god
yeah you are i'm sorry i sent you some
anxiety about the future that you don't
know she's doing great listen you're
just a wonderful nerd is what you are
yeah i mean you just you love you love
getting in these numbers and bathing
around these numbers talk to you the
fact you're even thinking about the
stuff and talking about it they're
amazing
you are so wonderful you're going to do
so much better than your feelings are
telling you you're gonna do
uh because not because you worry and
fret but because you pay attention
and because you got an incredible
freaking start
at 22 yourself this is a good problem to
have so listen you invest 15 you still
have 85 of your gross income at your
disposal to accomplish all of your life
goals funding college paying off the
home early going on vacation yeah you
guys are gonna be great you're gonna be
a millionaire when you're 30.
oh my gosh easy easy slam dunk